اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى هذه المقابله
الخاصه مع السيد اندريل يوشينكو سفيرا
بيلاروسيا في الامارات العربيه المتحده
اهلا بك سيد اندريس وشكرا على هذه
المقابله الخاصه لنا على شاشه العربيه
في البدايه نوادي الحديث عن الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه الكثيرون يعتقدون ان بلا روسيا
جزء اساسي من هذه الحرب باعتبارها حنيفا
استراتيجيا قويا لموسكو منذ لحظات الاولى
لهذه الحرب
اه ياسر بدويه
الصراع العسكريه بين روسيا
وكرانيا
والوضع بسبب هو اننا على حدود مع الدولتين
روسيا واوكرانيا الوضع على الحدود
الاوكرانيه خطير جدا بالنسبه لنا لانه
وفقا
فهو
اكتوبر
15 جندي اوكراني كانوا على الحدود
الاوكرانيه قلب الروسيه اااه ارسلتهم
اوكرانيا
نجد ان هناك تجسس همم
طائرات مسيره همم تعبر حدودنا الجويه لذلك
نتخذوا مثل هذه الخطوات الاحتياطيه للردي
على هذه التحركات وعلى تعزيزي حدودنا
الجنوبيه
امر لابد ان ينتهي ونحن كحليف
لروسيا نحن دوله ضمن الاتحاد مع روسيا
هو ان ندعم حليفنا ومنذ هذا اليوم
مهماتنا الاساسيه هي ليست
لان يكون
لدول الغرب فرصه لطعنه من من الظهر في في
روسيا وبالتالي لا نريد ان نشتغل على هذا
الاوروبيه قالت انكم شريك في هذه الحرب
اطلقت صواريخ من الاراضي الروسيه بعد
تقارير دوليه قالت عن مشاركه قوات من
بيلاروسيا في هذه الحرب هذا ادى الى فرض
عقوبات عليكم كطرف داعم او طرف مساند له
موسكو في هذه الحرب كيف تلقيتم هذه
العقوبات
اه
الناس
نحن نعتبر هذه العقوبات غير قانونيه لكن
علينا مواجهه وما من خيار سوى ذلك
استغرقنا الوقت شهرين الى ثلاثه لنجد
تجهيزات اللوجستيه
لدولتنا
همم
وعلاقاتنا التجاريه مع اكثر من 140 دوله
في العالم
وبالتالي علينا ايجاد الطرق لبيع منتجاتنا
يستغرقنا ثلاث اشهر لايجاد ترتيبات
اللوجستيه وطرق جديده بديله للدفع لان
العقوبات لم تؤثر فقط على ترتيبات
اللوجوسيه بل ايضا التعاون المصرفي حتى
الان
زي همم
القول اننا نتعاملنا مع الوضع ومن
اعتقدوا ان الامر سيكون صعب علينا كانوا
مخطئين ااا
غريب لكنه
اقتصادنا شهيدنا نموه بعد ذلك
ولم يكن في البدايه سهل والعقوبات ليست
امر سعيد لاي طرف لكننا عندنا تغيير
توجيه تجارتنا من الغرب الى الشرق الى
اسواق جديده
كويس
الدول
لديكم حسابات سياسيه في البدايه ان الحرب
يمكن ان تنجز سريعا لصالح موسكو
لا اعتقد
على هذا السؤال اين ومتى ستنتهي الحرب
فالجميع يقول
اننا نريد ان يحل السلام باسرع ما يمكن
حتى الان
الطرفين
احدهما ليس مستعدا لاجراء هذا الحوار
موقف الروسي
تم تصريح عنه وهو واضح ومفهوم
واقترحوا
مباحثات السلام على الشروط
الموجوده الان
لكن الطرف الثاني
ليس سيده ما يقولون فهم لن يجروا هذه
المفاوضات الان
بيلاروسيا لمحاوله عقد مفاوضات للسلام
نجحت في بعض الاحيان في فرض ايام من
الهدنه السماح لمرور بعض المحاصرين لكن هل
تعتقدون انكم قادرون فعلا على ان تكونوا
طرف رئيسي راعي للحوار للمفاوضات حقيقيه
بين روسيا واوكرانيا في الوقت الحالي
ميد رايدر بصراحه
وتمكنا من اداره وترتيبي
ثلاث جولات من المفاوضات في اذار لكن الان
هذه المفاوضات معلقه
دوله
[موسيقى]
سكانها في الحرب العالميه الاخيره
ونقدر الارواح البشريه
وكل اسره في بلاروس
لديها
فردا همم
قضى في تلك الحرب لذلك نفهم قيمه السلام
ونريد ان للسلام القنوات الدبلوماسيه
موجوده وقد
اخرجنا سفرتنا بنكيه في بدايه العمليه
العسكريه لكن السفاره
الاوكرانيه في بلدنا موجوده
لذلك
القنوات الدبلوماسيه موجوده
الا انها
[موسيقى]
وكانها
موجوده
من بلادي ان تكون وسيطا وان تقوم بالدور
اللازم لاحلال السلام لابد من الاطراف ان
تتحرك نعم في حديثك تشير الى ان ربما هناك
طرف هو الذي لا يريد السلام الحقيقي الان
وتقصد كما فهمت انا اوكرانيا هل تحملون
اوكرانيا مسؤوليه عدم وجود مسار حقيقي
لا لا
ما يبي اكسبريس ما يستوي
التعبير عن نفسي لكن
الجميع يريد السلام ولكن كل طرف لديه
شروطه كي يبدا المباحثات مباحثات السلامه
تختلف هذه الشروط من روسيا الى اوكرانيا
اوكرانيا لديهم
نجاحات
عسكريه وهم يشعرون بالانتصار
والمجتمع الاوكراني
اوضحها
بكل صراحه انهم يريدون ان يستعيدوا
سلطتهم على اراضيهم
بما فيها الكرم
هذا ما قاله وزير الخارجيه كلنا سمعنا ذلك
ولا اعرف ان كانت هذه الشروط ستكون
حوار عندما تستعد الاطراف ستبدا المفاوضات
لكنني لا اريد
طرفه اخر فلا احد همم
هل حانت لحظه السلام ام انها لم تاتي بعد
دعم مصر
عن ذلك
فلس رايي
لا يمكن ان يمثل اي طرف عليك ان تسالي هذا
السؤال
يشعر بانتصارات قد حققها على الارض
والمتابعين ايضا لهذه الحرب فوجئوا بان
قوه عسكريه كروسيه بحلفاء اقوياء بلا
روسيا لا تلقى نتائج عسكريه كبيره على
الارض شاهدنا انسحابات الروس من غير سون
من بعض المناطق هذه كانت مفاجاه هل كانت
مفاجاه لكم ايضا
اكسترا
على هذا السؤال
كما تطلعون عليها واعتقد
ان الامر كان غير متوقع بالنسبه لي شخصيا
وربما لكي وربما
ليفربول
العسكريه في كلا البلدين
لكنني لا استطيع ان احكم من جانبي على هذا
الامر طيب هل هناك اتصالات من الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه معكم لمساله فتح قنوات
مع روسيا للتفاوض تعلم ان هناك تقديرات
امريكيه تشير الى ان امريكا راغب الان في
تقريب وجهه النظر ما بين اوكرانيا وروسيا
لعقد المفاوضات للسلام هل تم اتصالات من
اي اطراف الدوليه معكم للقيام بدور الوسيط
اوف سمعته
انا احد مساعدين حاول
ان يوحي بان انه لابد من بدء مباحثات
السلام
على مستوى رفيع كما قلت ان احد الاطراف
يبدو ليس مستعدا لهذه المباحثات
اوروبا مع الامريكان
يحاولون الدفع باتجاه ذلك لكن ليس بكامل
قوام اما بالنسبه للدول الاخرى فليس هناك
من جرب او حاول
كل خطاب للرئيس الفرنسي ولا رئيس الصيني
وقيادات دول كثيره في العالم
مساعدين
للتدخل من اجل احنا للسلام لكن كما قلت لك
عندما تكون الطرفين مستعده كلنا سنكون
مستعدين
مع دبلوماسي لكن هل في اي لحظه كانت لديكم
مخاوف من ان يتم الدفع بكم كطرف راسي في
هذا الصراع بشكل كبير
قال الرئيسنا اننا لن نشارك في هذه الحرب
عوره
تندلع هذه
المواجهات الى اراضينا فلا يوجد اي
جندي من جنودنا على ارض اوكرانيا نحن نحمي
اراضينا ونعزز حدودنا مع اوكرانيا
عمله بسيطه
تعرضنا للهجوم عندما نتعرض للهجوم ستكون
مسؤوليتنا الرد هذا هو الامر الذي لا نريد
ان نفكر به في حاله الهجوم فقط
الازمه الكبيره المتعلقه بسقوط صواريخ على
بولندا كيف كانت تقييم الاوليه لهذه
اللحظه لانها كانت لحظه فارقه الكل كان
يخشى من مواجهه واسعه مع دول حلفنيته
اه
النوم
ليس لدينا هذه المخاوف
فقد اكد نيته ان الصواريخ
هي اوكرانيه
وقعت على الاراضي البولنديه
وقفها هو لا يوجد اي خسائر و ضحايا ولا
اعتقد ان هناك مواجهات معناته
لم يعلن اي شيء
سواء الرابع او الخامس
روسيا في الامارات العربيه المتحده ولكن
تم التعاون تجاري كبير مع دول المنطقه
الامارات والسعوديه والبحرين كيف يمكن ان
تصف لنا هذا التعاون وخاصه فيما يتعلق
بالتبادل التجاري
اه
تحدثنا عن التجاره مع دول مجلس التعاون
الخليجي بشكل عام نحن دائما نريد ان تكون
هذه العلاقه اكبر واوسع
لكن
منذ اليوم
مع الامارات وهو اكبر شريك تجاري من بين
دول الخليج مع بلال روسيا تتراوح بين
من 80 الى
الدولار
في السنه ليس برقم كبير لي اييي الامارات
لكننا نحن لسنا بعملاق اقتصادي وليس دوله
جوار فالمئه مليون بالنسبه لنا هو رقم مهم
هذا يؤدي الى ارتفاع عوائدنا
بالطراد مع دول الاخرى
العلاقات المتقدمه اكثر من سواها هي مع
الامارات مع السعوديه
بوسع القول اننا في بدايه الطريق لكنني
لانهم افتتاح المملكه والاصلاحات التي
تجري نامل باذن الله ان نبني علاقات قويه
ومتينه هذا ما امل
في هذه المقابله شكرا لك